[Music]
thank you
welcome everyone to Google Cloud next
it's wonderful to be back in person with
everyone for the first time since 2019.
you're here today because you're
interested in hearing about real-time
intelligence and how we can change your
business
you may be wondering how can my
organization take advantage of the power
of real-time intelligence and make it
work with my existing Investments
you may be concerned or skeptical that
adding real-time intelligence to your
workflows may be a little too costly or
a little too cumbersome or maybe a
little bit too confusing
my name is Sacha nagarwal I'm a product
lead here at Google cloud in our data
analytics organization and I'm super
excited to be with you today
I'll be covering how Google thinks about
real-time intelligence
talk a little bit about how some of our
customers have seen benefits I'll spend
a little bit of time on some of the
recent innovations that we have and then
I'll be very excited to have Chris and
kidar from Ulta beauty join me on stage
to talk about their successes with
real-time intelligence then we'll close
with some next steps and call to action
and then have q a with you being able to
ask us your questions
sound good
let's get into it
so let's get started by talking about
the state of real-time intelligence
today
organizations everywhere in all sorts of
Enterprises every Geo every industry are
making investments in real time decision
making and the Way That We Gather
process visualize and activate real-time
data is new and transforming our
business processes almost all the
organizations eighty percent in this
report and even more in our experience
are really looking at operationalizing
real-time intelligence with machine
learning in AI
the real key to capitalize is understand
that real-time intelligence is about
those minute Split Second opportunities
to make Better Business decisions
leading to Better Business outcomes
and real-time data is being generated
more than ever before everything's
connected we've been talking about the
internet of things for many times
talking about server-to-server
interaction having data flows and data
meshes and all of this moving together
and then adding on top of that this
generative AI moment where we need to
gather the data process it and take
advantage of these ml models and
artificial intelligence and really make
sense of this information so that we
realize these Better Business outcomes
talking about increasing our Revenue
talking about reducing our costs talking
about furthering the bottom line talking
about better unique transformative
differentiated customer experiences to
increase your lifetime value and you're
seeing this again in all sorts of
Industries you're seeing it in social
media you're seeing it with different
devices we're seeing with multi-channel
Commerce when we're bridging online and
offline worlds and again these AI
applications generative AI with models
that need to be updated in real time and
applied to our real-time data feeds
so let's get down to business
let's get down to real return on
investment eighty percent of
organizations are seeing increased top
line revenue through a leveraging
real-time data some examples
personalized offers and omni-channel
visibility
62 percent of organizations are seeing
efficiency in productivity games leading
to lower costs and better bottom line
performance and you can see that with
predictive maintenance when we're
talking about heavy machinery or our
supply chain it speaking of supply chain
how do we make sure that our assortment
is adapting in real time so we don't
have wastage and breakage and spoilage
in our warehouses and look at that last
number almost 100 percent of
organizations are seeing increased
customer satisfaction leading to higher
lifetime value and actually reduced
customer acquisition costs examples of
better fraud detection so you have a
better checkout experience Network
reliability making sure you have
capacity and availability when
organizations and customers need to take
advantage of your network
personalized care Internet connected
devices personalized Health Care better
outcomes
real-time intelligence really does
transform the way in which we look at
interact and activate our business
processes our teams our employees to
have better business outcomes for our
customers
you take advantage of real time
obviously with Google Cloud we have an
approach that we think makes sense and
is differentiated by being truly
Universal we are thinking about all
engagement from customers to machines to
team members to Partners we're talking
about all different kinds of analytics
machine learning Transformations batch
real-time dashboarding all kinds of data
not specialized streaming data only but
a truly unified system that takes your
batch data your streaming data your
structured data your semi-structured
data video audio photos bringing it all
together in our unified data ecosystem
so you can take advantage of the
information you have and layer on top
these benefits of real time and
streaming and again the speed it's not a
standalone streaming real-time system
it's deeply integrated with your
existing Investments through our
Partnerships through our commitment to
open source and through our big platform
of Partners over 1 000 Partners on the
Google Cloud platform and growing every
day and of course this is globally
available Google cloud is one of the
major hyperscaler clouds with more
locations than ever before and with
unparalleled uptime over five nines of
uptime worldwide you heard us talk in
today's keynote about security that we
have unique and differentiated in Google
Cloud so that these benefits are
available to you your customers your
partners your employees when you need it
when you need to rely on it
and so here is how we do it this is our
fully integrated golden path Cloud
native to Google Cloud we have pubs up
for messaging dataflow for truly unified
batch and streaming data processing with
power of ml built in bigquery our Cloud
native data warehouse you know
pioneering the separation of storage and
compute built in with vertex AI we've
had this ml framework and these
possibilities and this moment is here
and we have met at the moment with
vertex Ai and looker obviously Next
Generation business intelligence
real-time dashboarding seeing
visualization so organizations
individuals can make sense of this data
and just below you can see the different
ways in which this works from activation
the choice that I talked about open
source Partners continuous model
training making sure that we're taking
advantage of real-time data as we
generate it so that our models aren't a
day a month a year behind where we are
today and of course activating those
insights it's more than just dashboards
it's more than just real-time visibility
or predictions it's real time activation
how do we make changes in application
state for Better Business outcomes it's
the power of real time and the deeply
integrated Google data and AI
infrastructure that we've thoughtfully
made sure works well together so that
you can recognize these benefits in as
short a time frame as possible so again
what does this Roi look like with
numbers
well Forester conducted a total economic
analysis for us and used just one part
of that solution with dataflow this is
based on a composite organization that
again Forester has independently put
together and you can see this
increase in developer productivity over
50 percent infrastructure cut
infrastructure costs excuse me cut in
half
payback time measured in months not
years speaking to How Deeply this
integrates with existing Investments you
don't have to create a parallel new
complex infrastructure and then have a
migration and of course that return on
investment that number 171 percent
it
you know it makes total sense right less
than a year almost double your return it
makes a ton of sense and then when you
layer on top some of our other products
like vertex AI which shows a 387 percent
ROI or looker which shows a 480 Roi
think of the compounding effects of
taking advantage of the Google Cloud
native golden path for real-time
intelligence and of course you can talk
to your account teams and we're happy to
provide these reports to you but it's
really interesting when you start
layering on top these benefits and
seeing these compounding effects
here's a real world example our
customerbooking.com is one of the
world's largest
Spenders on digital ads they have this
ginormous PPC pay-per-click ad
infrastructure that responds in real
time to changes in weather changes in
events changes in customer demand and
other signals that they see and what
they've done is they change their
creative they change their bidding
strategy in a matter of Moments by
incorporating real-time data
they've mentioned that their spent is in
the billions with a B dollars per year
when they talk about their overall
marketing spend and their PPC is a very
substantial proportion of this so you
can imagine what the ROI is here it's
measured
um it's measured in millions of dollars
and you can see what that means with a
very short implementation cycle
30 times reduction in implementation
time cutting down that system cutting
down that learning cutting down that
flywheel between Gathering data
processing data and activating that data
from hours down to minutes and working
on making that even faster down to fewer
minutes and even seconds
so I'm really excited to talk about some
of our latest Innovations in our
products and we have a couple of deep
dive sessions later in Cloud next
tomorrow and Thursday and I'll cover
that a little bit later
so as I mentioned Pub sub is our truly
Cloud native Global partitionless
differentiated messaging infrastructure
and we've been really really excited to
make it even easier for organizations to
get data with Pub sub from where it is
to where it needs to be last year we
introduced bigquery subscriptions which
allows you to stream data directly into
bigquery and use it for elt workloads
now we're bringing that same Simplicity
for your data Lakes use cases with
direct to Google Cloud Storage
subscriptions it makes it so easy it
gives you simplified data pipelines
lower latency and lower costs and
increased flexibility because there are
batching options if you need it
flexibility and how you want to deploy
it and because we have the separation
between Publishers and subscribers in
Pub sub you can attach these new
subscriptions to your existing topics
yet again one of the ways that we
intentionally invest in making sure that
you're in your existing Investments can
be leveraged in new and fundamental ways
another exciting Innovation that we have
is dataflow ml this was announced at
Cloud next last year and we've been very
excited to see organizations taking
advantage of the power of data flow the
truly unified batch and streaming data
processing and bringing that to bear for
machine learning use cases
run inference allows you to do machine
learning inference with just a few lines
of code and allows you to do so with a
variety of ml Frameworks including Pi
torch scikit-learn Nvidia Rapids and of
course Google's own tensorflow
automatic model updates again when I
talked about making sure that your ml
models aren't stuck in time that you
didn't just train them once and then
leave them out there to atrophy as you
get new data the power of data flow
allows you to continually update those
models so that your real-time
inferencing is as good as possible
because the world isn't static we are
learning constantly and things are
changing data flow plus vertex working
together provides a truly end-to-end
real-time streaming machine learning
infrastructure for both training and
activation and this is unique to us at
Google and speaking of tight integration
with vertex we have really spent a lot
of time making the developer experience
as good as possible we know that it is
hard it is difficult to find these
machine learning Engineers so it's
incumbent on us to make them as
productive as possible and so with full
ml op support tight integration with
vertex AI pipelines we're allowing these
machine learning Engineers to spend more
time on code and less time on
infrastructure and all the other cludge
what we call toil to make those things
happen
so this is critically critically
important and a differentiator for what
makes data flow and the Google data and
AI Cloud unique for real-time
intelligence
the last one that I want to talk about
is more investments in developer
experience Beyond just machine learning
so we've really tried to make it as easy
as possible for organizations to
understand and realize the benefits of
streaming through eliminating the need
to manage infrastructure one of the
things that we've worked on is Right
fitting
um Dynamic thread scaling and asymmetric
scaling
to essentially make it as easy as
possible for the data flow system to
handle all the infrastructure adding
workers removing workers when you don't
need it so that it scales up and down so
you have no wasted spend while you're
still getting those business outcomes
the real-time outcomes that you need to
have
one of the common sources of performance
problems in a streaming pipeline can be
stragglers or late arriving data these
items take much longer to process than
other types of data this is one of the
things that we've really really focused
on because we may not control the source
systems that are feeding into us and so
we don't want to cut them off we don't
want to eliminate them from our
processes we want to handle them in an
efficient way we spent a lot of time
making that as good as possible by
really automatically determining the
cause of that straggler and making it
easy for you to heal your Pipelines
Dynamic destinations I talked before
about how we are intentional about
making our products work well together
Dynamic destinations for Pub sub
messages allow you to move Pub sub
messages to the right Downstream system
based on certain attributes that you
define this saves you money and it saves
you time
and the way that it saves you money is
by not having duplicate data that you
then have to filter at the destination
system we do that further Upstream so
only the right information gets to the
right place and because you do that
Upstream it saves Time same as the toil
of having to re-implement that
deduplication infrastructure over and
over and over again imagine that you're
using Pub sub's new payload on rubbing
technology for reverse ETL use cases
we have a hundred a hundred
a hundred record across just your
marketing stack alone
this capability makes it super easy for
you to make sure that the right
information is getting to the right
operational systems to drive your
businesses
and lastly I mentioned regular detection
but another thing that we have is data
sampling I how do we make sure that you
as a developer can go and inspect what's
happening in your pipelines well we can
automatically sample the actual data
that's happening so you have a reference
as to what's happening it's one of those
trust but verify we're making sure that
you have the tools at hand to fully
understand your systems so that you can
make Better Business Direction
and I'd love to talk about another
customer that's been super successful
tell us an organization in Canada that
does Telecom they've seen their data
processing times reduced dramatically a
20x reduction by taking on data flow and
using it for its truly unified batch and
streaming capabilities
and what's the Better Business outcome
that they've been able to see
a 50 percent increase success rate in
automatic customer resolution
faster time to resolution
happier customers reduce costs increased
Revenue through the power of real-time
intelligence
I'd love to invite Kata and Chris up to
the stage now to talk about their
successes with Google's real-time
intelligence Solution please give them a
hand
[Applause]
welcome gentlemen and
hello hi everyone
you can see who is who now yep so why
don't we start with you why don't you
tell us just a little bit about Ulta and
what makes Ulta unique and different
sure yeah I'll be happy to how many
people here are shopping have shopped at
Ulta or have someone in their household
a lot of hands good stuff very good all
right I think most of you know who we
are we are by far the largest specialty
Beauty retailer here in the United
States and you know you can see it on
the page here right we believe Beauty
does make the world a better place
um you know we believe build these
beauties for Everyone We Believe beauty
is it brings out the best in everyone
and that's the entire business that we
have built around this entity of beauty
that brings Joy to the World so next
page please
um so a few facts and figures about who
we are as a company so we are a publicly
traded company one of the like I said
the largest beauty retail in the US uh
we are about 10 billion dollars in
Revenue we have a significant uh
presence in terms of stores as well as
our Ecom business uh we are amongst the
top top highest fastest growing
retailers out here in the United States
and one of the one of the most proudest
things that we have for us is our
loyalty program we have over 41 million
active members as of last week we had
our earnings call all and we have over
41 million active loyalty members on our
loyalty card right and that generates a
tremendous amount of data by which we
can do really wonderful things in terms
of our our customer interactions and
then one final quick page please and
what makes us special is really our what
I call our secret sauce on a page you
can see the key aspects of our strategy
that have really been contributing to
Our Success so it all starts with our
our store base where we have a very
strategic realized real estate asset
base that we leverage for promoting and
uh you know encouraging our customers to
engage with beauty we have a very wide
assortment we have essentially all
things beauty all Under One Roof we have
of course our very strong digital
experience model uh it dries very well
with that's what I think brings us a lot
of power being able to you know combine
our brick and mortar experience with our
digital experiences and then of course
you know our loyalty program which I
talked about one of our crown jewels and
finally our services business not many
people know that we also have a full
service Salon in almost every single
store and that creates a significant
stickiness factor with our customers and
provides their all their beauty needs
Under One Roof so that's kind of what
Ulta beauty is we are like I said one of
the biggest retailers in in Beauty and
we do some amazing things in terms of
data that's actually I'm gonna pass it
over to my colleague Krish who's going
to talk about what we are doing with
data cool all right thanks Kelly this is
a really great intro so you'll see the
name Darwin you can read it as Evolution
right there's a it's an acronym for a
longer thing but as Keda mentioned we
have 41 million loyalty active customers
right they make millions and millions of
transaction we have six plus
Distribution Center so that means we are
actually sitting on the gold mine of
information
but it it just doesn't give you a value
until you have a solid foundation that
ensures that you have really good
quality data
that is reliable available at the real
time or near real time right and it's
available for the business usage in a
self-service mode because if they are
constantly relying on some technology
partner
for making the data available it slows
down the process you know you mentioned
about Split Second decisioning right you
can't have too many handles right and
that's what we are doing but we have a
really big Vision there we as you're
setting the foundation with right set of
platform and Engineering that's scalable
makes data available real time we have
the right set of governance on top of it
but our vision is broader we're really
democratizing is across the organization
so that you know most of the time you
see the marketing starts with by
leveraging the information and all but
we are pushing it across all lines of
business or call it store operation
supply chain merchandising right Finance
so that we as an organization can really
really extract the value of our data and
that's what we are doing as part of
Darwin yep that's awesome and it's
really really interesting to hear about
you talking about democratizing and
getting
things out of the loop so people can
self-service that's great you know you
mentioned things around merchandising
around supply chain other areas do you
have a specific example where this
Darwin data platform has allowed those
end users to solve service and realize
Better Business outcomes
perhaps absolutely actually there are
quite a lot yeah let's start with loss
prevention so for those of you in the
retail industry as you can imagine the
this this organized crime right to
retail crime and the losses becomes a
big factor and it impacts the bottom
line so prior to this just a quick
example of it the prior to sitting up
Darwin right
we had loss prevention team creating
Excel spreadsheet from pulling
information with different places and
then emailing it out to the store or the
Distribution Center
and then getting feedback again and then
again collecting the information back
correcting it and feeding it back again
instead what we have done we have
actually the real-time data coming into
the secret system and it's available in
form of a dashboard So based on your
access level you can just go click click
click you get the information it's this
tremendous amount of efficiency again we
just realized and within a very short
period of time so that's that's a great
example then there are lots of other
examples of finance and supply chain
they're all looking at it yes I'll add
one more example to that we have you
know we have a large merchandising
function right of course we sell product
our product is ultimately we buy the
product from our various brand Partners
our Merchant team actually is using
price elasticity models developed by my
team to make better decisions on pricing
so they have price elasticity models
they can use to make inform and have
more productive data based discussions
with our brand Partners when we are
talking about seeing changes in in an
upcoming quarter or For an upcoming
season another quick real-time exam that
is not particularly real time but other
real-time example is personalization
right so we are constantly collecting
data signals as customers are looking at
our digital properties and using those
data signals to in fact inform real time
product recommendations or messaging or
reinforced messaging based on where they
might be in their life cycle and any
particular promotion that we may have
active at any given point of time no
that's awesome and one of the things
that's really great is you mentioned the
pricing example which is not necessarily
A real-time one but you have a single
system that you're using for your real
time and your batch use cases and being
able to bring data to those sometimes
difficult conversations maybe with your
brand Partners you know makes all the
difference in the world and so you have
to have trust in that that's exactly you
know we talked a little bit about the
functions inside your organization and
how they've benefited I'd love to hear
an example or two of how this benefits
the end consumer those 41 million people
in Ulta rewards the folks who come in
how are they benefiting those teenagers
that love you you know tell me how the
data platform with Darwin
you know really makes that better yeah I
think the biggest example I would
provide there is again in the realm of
personalization right so with 41 million
active members on our customer file the
we know you know our customers and most
of them are she right she's telling us
what she's buying when she's buying how
often when not all kinds of signals she
is giving us willingly it it is so much
powerful for them when we are using
those signals to make much more informed
and better messaging to them back back
in return right so it goes in the form
of personalization of emails it make it
goes in the form of personalization of
landing pages on our website uh it's in
the team in terms of personalizing the
app experience providing very specific
offers that may be relevant to a
particular person knowing what their
preferences are makes a hell of a lot of
a difference right in their lives when
they are ready to engage in the category
which it's almost every day I can
possibly add something if you look at
our
historically how a customer behave right
if you go back maybe 10 15 years back
the customer is happy to get a
offer on your mailbox right and react to
it maybe after two or three weeks
possibly take it out and then look at it
make a trip to mall and then use it
right I think those those days are gone
right
usually I don't know how many of you
open your mailbox and look at the offer
usually you toss it in the trash bag
trash can right so our new generation
expect
us to know them better right expect us
to know what their choices are so that
hyper personalization really really
knowing just beyond the information that
they usually provide but really
stitching together their behavior gonna
enable us or enable anyone to Target
them properly and that's what you're
doing that's how we are gaining the
traction in that constituents because
their pattern is completely changing and
we have to evolve uh based on the
pattern right you know you can Implement
these things and then they change the
response to it and then you can't have
been left behind that's right
continually update the way that you
engage the way that your models assume
what these interaction patterns are and
the data can be inside the 41 or outside
with other signals that you have as well
right exactly so it's really wonderful
thank you so much let me talk a little
bit about how everyone here in the
audience can realize the benefits that
you have and then we'll open it up for
your q a sound good
so a couple of things we have lots and
lots of ways to help you and your
organization realize these benefits and
I just want to highlight some of them
you can talk to your account team to
sign up for a hackvest workshop where
you can work with Google or a partner in
your environment to do a proof of
concept and see what's happening we have
lots of self-service and guided
trainings we have dataflow Academy you
know for one specific product to make it
super easy and we go in depth in person
with you on the power of data flow but
then we also have things like Coursera
and beam College where you can
self-service and share videos with your
team so you can learn some of these
tools across not only dataflow but the
rest of the Google data and AI stack and
you can accelerate your time to value by
well great artists deal we have
reference patterns and reference
architectures that you can look at for a
wide variety of use cases to see how to
use the Google data in AI products
together to realize better business
value
again there are some additional sessions
that I mentioned earlier machine
learning to streaming data that's
tomorrow at one o'clock and then
bigquery at the center of our data lake
house we have talking about continuous
real-time analytics and SQL bringing the
power of streaming in real time
democratizing it into all of our
products learning from each other is how
we do it internally to bring better
value meeting you where you are you can
learn more about that in the replay on
Thursday
and with every session here we do want
your feedback so please do complete the
session survey in the mobile app you
know five stars all the rest of it I am
your Uber driver for the day
and that'd be great I do want to leave
you with a story so I'm a photographer I
have been my entire life I started off
with uh you know those disposable
cameras the yellow ones when I got to
high school my dad gave me this which is
a yashika SLR that he had had when he
moved from India to the states
um and so in high school I I use this
took a lot of photos was in the uh the
dark room processing my photos and all
the rest of it well for those of you who
don't remember when we had film you only
had 24 exposures on a roll of film and
processing that film and developing
those photos took a fair amount of time
this really made you be judicious in
which pictures you took because you
wanted to be thoughtful about oila have
so many in my role oh you know the
expense and the tediousness of going
through and developing and processing
and making these photos you know was a
lot but now
we have photos we have cameras excuse me
in our pockets digital cameras on our
phones completely changes this right I
have an unlimited amount of storage on
my phone and in Google Cloud for my
Google photos that syncs with Nest hubs
so the photos that I take that I share
can immediately show up in the living
rooms of the grandparents of my two kids
they love this and what it allows me to
do is see exactly what photos I take in
real time I can tell immediately if the
kid was smiling or scowling or making a
face I can tell immediately if I was
shaking or my finger got in the lens or
all the rest of it in real time I can
tell the kid go sit smile we're doing
this again or I have captured the moment
and we can go on
the outcome I want hasn't changed in the
40 years of my life I want to capture
and share the memories that matter with
those who love my kids the most right
and that's exactly what we're doing with
real-time intelligence we're taking
advantage of new technology to solve the
same problems but with totally different
processes that transform the way we
think about it that eliminates some of
these barriers that allow us to achieve
those outcomes faster and with much more
confidence so I'd love to leave that
with you think about the ways where
there aren't incremental improvements by
going from batch or micro batch to real
time think about the fundamental
assumptions that you may have that no
longer apply in a real-time world that's
the power of real-time intelligence
thank you so much
foreign